et c'est vrai que c'est une guerre qui a
eu lieu il ya dix ans enfin à 15 ans et
que ça arrive encore aujourd'hui en
europe et partout à côté de l'europe
enfin c'est des histoires qui font
raconter c'est important et du coup on
d'une manière humble et vraiment tout
petit on a l'impression d'avoir un petit
drapeau et de lettres plat et jawala
regarder ce qui se passe près de chez
nous qu'est ce qu'on peut faire en tout
cas d'être au moins au courant et ne pas
les oublier qu'on sait ce que j'ai pour
le film je ne m'en rende compte
parce que voir que c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'était un peu le tournage quoi des
plombes l'information tout le mond
traduisent est mis nous allons donc
maintenant le kids u 13 et région de la
seconde édition
l'âge
jean luc godard vous savez moi quand je
donne des indications aux acteurs elles
sont j'essaie de faire en sorte qu'elle
soit toujours le plus technique le plus
précise possible le moins psychologique
mais je n'ai pas d idée a priori avant
que les acteurs se lancent j'ai besoin
quand même qu'ils prennent leur envol
voilà je suis en quelque sorte à un
assistant des acteurs comme taxi bus
voilà la ligne d'arrivée n'est plus très
loin et on connaît désormais les favoris
pour le prix très convoité du
festivalier le mieux à billes
ça se jouera entre eva longoria nicole
kidman laetitia casta et bien sûr notre
petit préféré
justin bieber qui a adopté le look j'ai
oublié mon t-shirt à hollywood mais
c'est pas ta parce que j'étais jolie
tétons
oh
jessica je sais que j'ai pas le droit de
vous poser la question mais c'est pour
ça que je vous avoue la pause on parle
de vous dans ce show détective
oui mais pendant de répondre la nouvelle
saison de l'émission
moi aussi j'adore pourtant mais je
serais ravi de découvrir la série très
bien j'ai la réponse vous serez donc
dans la nouvelle saison de true
détective
marion la salle était très émue fière
pas après la projection
ah ah bon vous êtes surpris beaucoup de
spectateurs pleurer d'ailleurs au c'est
gentil merci merci à vous tous merci
d'avoir versé tant de larmes
merci d'avoir pleuré comme des
madeleines c'est tellement gentil
d'avoir chialer comme des veaux et
d'être sorti la goutte au nez du cinéma
comme disait ma grand mère ça vaut mieux
qu'un coup de pied au cul
c
le
mais des histoires
et
il sait il est tombé mal se passer
non
m
essai
il
à l'est
et